are you still here you're busy I thought
you left oh my God I have to go but I
just wanted to make sure you're okay
like I don't want to leave like
with your man
today is my last day of the church in
L.A and I'm feeling terrible
because I really like Josh and I I just
hoped that this trip would bring us
closer
and I was hoping we would talk about his
commitment kids you know us none of that
happen
I don't know what's going on right now
Josh I come here you sleep with me and
after you tell me bye okay go I have to
go to put all the mob oh I'm in a
different country I don't have work I'm
still married
for you and you don't even have time for
me go okay okay bye I'm sorry that you
feel this way it does it will not help
okay I care for you I'm gonna give you
some time to cool off oh please okay
I'll text you later if you don't if you
don't block me okay
oh
uh honestly I'm at a loss for words
she knew going into like
this week like this was my deadline time
no matter what happened this was my time
I I have to go to work imagine you know
like
how my kids feel when I have to go to
work all the time like that I mean they
understand it and they're five
I think she wants me to be like this
normal guy that is just like
running after her and
you know like I'm not 15 years old like
I can't just be running after people all
the time I have
things that I have to do
listen you could buy me ticket now and
say come with me go down here he has
plenty of me of this beautiful girls who
travel with him I don't understand
sex is serious if I sleep this evening
but if I didn't consider him my mind and
father my kids why would they do it to
myself
uses me
[Music]